نحاول ندبر حالنا يعني بدل ما ناكل ثلاث
وجبات اليوم صرنا ناكل وجبتين نتاقلم
قاعدين ولكن الفعل حالي ماساويه يعني
[موسيقى]
اكثر من اننا كمملكه اردنيه هاشميه
تجاوزنا طاقاتنا الاستيعابيه لا لن نستطيع
ان نستمر في تقديم الخدمات الضروريه
لتوفير العيش الكريم للاجئين الا اذا
التزم المجتمع الدولي ايضا
بمسؤولياته وقام بما عليه فعله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من القرار هذا عن جد دمر حياتنا يعني كثير
الاجار كيف بدنا ندفعه الكهرباء المي كيف
ابكي بصراحه انا وامي صرنا نبكي للامانه
يعني لانه هذا يعني هذا مصدر دخل وقفوا
لنا اياه عندي اولاد صغار بدهم حليب بدهم
فوط ما في معين والاب مسائل
[موسيقى]
نحن في الاردن قمنا بكل ما هو ممكن لتوفير
العيش الكريم لاشقائنا السوريين حوالي
مليون و300 الف شقيق منهم لكن
تراجع الدعم الدولي واعلان منظمات امنيه
مثل برنامج غذاء الدولي وقف مساعداته
سيزيد من معاناه اللاجئين
[موسيقى]